why does Sam Altman CEO of open AI chat
GPT carries a blue backpack everywhere
he goes hear me out hear me out to carry
his stuff
okay I'm back what happened uh while I
was gone today we're going to look at
the last one and a half months of AI
development had to take a bit of a break
everything well now let's go
the probably biggest thing that happened
is the introduction of llama 2 meta
released a successor to the Llama model
that is upgraded so it's been
pre-trained on two trillion tokens it
has a context length that's double the
context length of the last lava model
and it exists in various sizes 7 13 and
70 billion parameters although there is
a 30-ish 35-ish billion parameter model
that has not been released yet because
they say they hadn't had sufficient time
to red team and explore its safety most
notably llama 2 is commercially friendly
licensed so it's not open source it's
not non-commercial it's something
strange the younger can't tweeted this
out llama V2 is open source with a
license that authorizes commercial use
this is going to change the landscape of
the llm market yada yada yada and I have
to say it's not open source I would lead
with people to stop using this term
unless something actually conforms with
open source specifications which this
model doesn't you're not free to use it
for whatever you want in fact the
license says you're free to use the
model commercially up to a limit of 700
million users meaning monthly active
users so essentially you can use it if
you're doing like a small scale
operation but as soon as you get to 700
million monthly active users you'll have
to go to meta and then ask them for
permission or they ask you for money or
they can just deny it hello there it's
Yannick from the future I was just cross
checking if I got this license actually
right and I think I made a mistake uh
reading it the first time and I also
feel a lot of other people uh also
didn't read it as accurately so let's
correct that right now the license says
if on the Llama 2 version release date
the monthly active users of the products
or Services May made available buyer for
licensee or licenses Affiliates is
greater than 700 million monthly active
users in the preceding calendar month
you must request a license from meta
which meta May ground you or not the
crucial part being it says on the Llama
2 version release date so the Llama 2
version release date is defined up here
somewhere as July 18
2023 so in this case only already
existing services or products with this
many users would not be allowed to use
llama without going to meta now while I
still think that's kind of crappy
essentially it says like anyone can use
it except you know you Telegram and
Google or and and other like it it's
still kind of crappy and it's absolutely
against the spirit of Open Source and I
think they could still achieve their
mission of fueling research and stifling
open AI by just fully releasing it I'm
going to make some claims here in this
video that are then less valid I'm going
to say for example well if you have a
startup and the startup grows and builds
upon llama 2 and reaches 700 million
users you're essentially in danger of
matter cutting you off according to as
the way I understand the license this is
not the case
um what is the case is that you probably
wouldn't want to remain at llama too you
probably would want to build upon future
versions as well and is quite
conceivable that if meta goes this right
now that future versions will also have
this thing in
um on yeah on the other hand what does
it mean the products or Services made
available by or for licensee like what
what does that mean in in what way like
if you're a provider of a telegram
plugin and telegram has the X-Men users
but your plugin doesn't yet or like
there's all these kinds of questions and
I feel still this is kind of crappy to a
lot of especially startups who yeah
future versions are going to be out of
question and even current versions
you're probably gonna have to hire a
lawyer or something in many cases well
in any case
um I feel I'm I wasn't super duper wrong
but I was at least a little bit wrong so
consider that
so it's not open source and I know Jan
Le car has been one of the driving
forces between meta becoming the most
open source or release friendly company
there is which 10 years ago someone
would have told you like Facebook
research was gonna be the most open
company there is it would be absolute
you would laugh them out of the room
right and Jan has been a driving force
behind that and from everything that I
can estimate from the outside there's
been a lot of movement inside of this
company to strive towards more openness
and that's absolutely laudable that's
really really cool let's not use the
word open source where they don't belong
the code is open the model is available
but it's not open source you're not free
to do whatever you want that being said
meta has also collected let's say
supporting a cast signatures of sort
young tweets a number of personalities
from industry and Academia have endorsed
our open source approach which I find to
be very interesting so I pulled that up
here they have gone to people very
various Natures academics VCS and so on
with this statement we support an open
Innovation approach to AI responsible
and open Innovation gives us all a stake
in the AI development process bringing
visibility scrutiny and Trust to these
Technologies opening today's llama
models will let everyone benefit from
this technology and the list of
signatories is long and notably includes
VCS such as partners from Andresen
Horowitz Partners from other capitals
sv-like so these are investors and VCS
who somehow signed a statement in
support for meta's approach to licensing
which to me is super duper Shady so if
you read this statement right here
notably they leave away the part where
it's like hey if you have more than 700
million users you have to come to us
what I think is that the people here
might not have been fully aware of what
they were signing up for essentially
signing this statement Right Here and
Now meta is selling it as these people
support our approach to licensing which
might be a bit Shady now it's totally
possible they might have convinced all
of these people I have my doubts with
all of this there's been a flurry of
development around llama 2 the community
has picked it up and it's really cool to
see that we get like an explosion of
development around it so llama 2
accessory is an open source toolkit to
do anything and everything with the
Llama 2 model fine tuning and so on we
have together AI releasing long context
sizes for llama too so they extended the
Llama 2 models for long context using
position interpolation open chat has new
models based on llama 2. lmc's released
the kuna models based on llama 2 and
they appear to be quite performant and
much much more so a lot of people are
now building on top of llama 2 which is
extremely extremely cool notably La mod
2 does not only come as a pre-trained
language model which you can fine-tune
but meta has also made a fine-tuned
versions of that including chat use
cases in order to sort of chat with the
model so lots of bases of new
developments
all right Next News uh Google publishes
on their blog a new partnership to
promote a responsible AI saying that
Google Microsoft open Ai and anthropic
are announcing the formation of the
Frontier Model Forum a new industry body
focusing on ensuring safe and
responsible development of Frontier AI
models Frontier being I guess the new
cool term for foundation models I
welcome the dismemberment of the term
Foundation models but this it's almost
like ridiculous first of all meta
notably absent from this body I don't
know if whether by own choice or by
exclusion but having these companies
make a is essentially what they want to
do is influence government they want to
influence policy makers academic civil
society and so on they want to make the
laws to preserve their monopolistic
status it's so ridiculous that this
builds the body of safe development of
AI it's like having Lord Voldemort in
charge of the safe deployment of magic
it's just kind of backwards and I don't
doubt that there are people in all of
these companies who are super well
intended on the safe development of AI
but that's just not what's going to
happen with an organization like this
we've already seen open AI doing their
absolute best to essentially Lobby
policy makers to entrench their
monopolistic status and this is just
gonna be accelerating that
in better news NASA and IBM openly
release a geospatial AI Foundation model
for the NASA Earth observation data so
this is a foundation model that is fed
with satellite imagery and this can be
used for all kinds of things because now
you can fine tune that to do let's say
you want to predict how much forests
grow or Shrink or something like this so
this model will already have inherent
capabilities in order to be fine-tuned
for such a task think of it as a
pre-trained resnet that people have been
using for all kinds of stuff but just
for satellite imagery it's very cool and
it comes from obviously NASA's vast
extensive collection of satellite
imagery data and look at this is Apache
licensed wow people can do this and I'm
pretty sure no one has been hurt or
harmed as of now by a better
understanding of satellite imagery is
really not that hard and thank you NASA
thank you IBM for participating in this
very cool
all right we're gonna go a bit faster
over some new models that have been
released some new big models and we'll
just touch a little bit what they are
all the links are in the description
chameleon by meta is a text to image and
image to text model so it is a
pre-trained model that combines image
and text in a two-way fashion although I
don't think or I haven't found them
releasing any of the models but it's
still very cool what you can do with it
visual question answering all kinds of
image editing you can fine tune it to do
things and the multimodal world in AI is
progressing and the same can be said
about rt2 which is Google deepmind's new
model for robotics so they previously
investigated a lot into robotics models
including with their previous rt1 model
but what this does very well is it
combines robotic data so data from
robots interacting with things and
having instructions along with that with
data just scraped from the into internet
and that gives the robots a much better
understanding just of the world so they
mix internet scale vqa and robot data
and that mix enables a much better
understanding as I said and it's also
really nice to see that the advances of
the other domains of machine learning
where we say hey we have all this
unsupervised essentially data laying
around how about we learn a lot from
that large volume of data and then we
mix in some targeted data in this case
robotics instruction data and get the
best of both worlds so these robots here
are able to do extremely let's say tasks
where you actually need to understand
stuff need to understand the scene and
implicitly make some assumptions they're
very often good at doing things such as
pick object that is different it's a
fairly high level and let's say abstract
task and by having that pre-training on
large amounts of data and that language
understanding and the visual
understanding the robots can actually
perform that Google research releases
Med Palm 2 which is a progression on
their Med on paper so this is a
foundation Frontier retrained whatever
model on medical data now whatever the
screeching horde of AI safety and ethics
people might say the vast majority of
people in the medical field will welcome
the help of such models and the model is
actually very very good at certain tasks
obviously won't replace doctors but it
can pass medical exams it can give
suggestions for diagnoses or suggestions
for all kinds of stuff here it's
compared to Physicians yellow bars are
Med Palm the blue bars they go from the
right are humans and in the middle there
are ties so for example omits more
information in five to ten percent of
the cases that they've looked at met
Palm omits more information than in
let's say 60 of the cases see Physicians
omitted more information nation and in
the rest thirty percent of the cases in
between here both parties omitted about
the same amount of information so that's
how you read these charts and you can
pretty much see that at least obviously
in the things that they've tested met
pump scores pretty well so it's
conceivable that in the near future
Physicians will get a lot of helpful
assistance from a medical models that
have been either just pre-trained or
fine-tuned on particular things
especially for the people who think the
louder they shout the word harm the more
they just get their way and get what
they want if you look at the bottom two
things right here greater extent of harm
and greater likelihood of harm
Physicians lead the pack well well
before mad Palm so I can definitely see
the obvious risks and models especially
since if it's just one model there it's
still good to have like even if the
Physicians are kind of wrong more if
they're wrong in different ways it might
like equalize each other other out a
little bit whereas a model is much more
likely to be wrong in a consistent
Direction all the time but on average in
this case in these cases you'd rather
have a physician with a model than a
physician without one they've also
fine-tuned or extended these models to
be multimodal and for example in this
case can you write me a report analyzing
this chest x-ray the model responds by
actually looking at the picture again
multi-modality coming in another release
by meta the open Catalyst demo is
accelerating Catalyst Discovery with AI
this is a more into the domain of
chemistry catalysts or reactants that
you add to a chemical reaction to make
them faster or to make them happen in
the first place they usually lower the
energy barrier the initial energy
barrier to get a chemical reaction
started and sustain it this is an
attempt to use AI models to figure out
how catalysts bind to structures and
therefore analyze which new catalysts
could be built to help certain reactions
I'm not into chemistry too much but they
do have a demo where you can try
yourself and they themselves say that
you know the models they aren't yet as
good as doing Quantum simulation but
obviously as we know machine learning
models in these types of simulation
scenarios have the advantage that they
can be much faster than running the
actual simulation so if you are
interested in the demo check out this
website I've tried it a bit I have no
clue what it does it seems sensible
anthropic announces Claude 2 so Claude
is anthropics large language model
notably Claude 1 had a hundred thousand
token context size which made it is
really really special and I think Claude
2 retains that 100
000 tokens complex size claw 2 has been
improved in various ways and notably
they now also have a little bit of a
website claude.ai where you can talk to
the model Within in your browser however
for us plebs who are not in the US and
UK you will have to wait for a little
bit until you get access to that meta
releases audio craft which is a code
base for generative audio needs as they
say and they have two models here one is
audiogen and one is music gen both are
text to Audio models and these text to
Audio models as we can see right here
from let's say a build up they are
trained as again sort of pre-trained
foundation Frontier models in order to
transform and reconstruct audio with the
gold and that you can let's say type in
how you want some music to sound and the
model will produce music or change a
piece of music to fit your description
more a core component of that is what
they call en codec en codec is a
compression audio compression codec that
is especially suited to deal with is
neural network models so whereas
previously we had things like MP3 or so
in order to compress audio now we're
building codecs in order to suit neural
models and if you can see right in the
middle right here that's at least that's
what I believe en codec had to be they
call it audio tokens and I have not
looked I have to say into the paper very
closely I will do so but the way I
interpret this is that it is
transforming the audio into a tokenized
representation which is you could assume
that it's almost kind of standard
nowadays you have any kind of signal you
make it into latent tokens but in their
case they call it residual codes which I
would assume that you have a base like
different layers of token and every
layer of token sort of gives you more
High Fidelity audio so the base layer
it's almost like you get like the low
frequencies and then you add the middle
frequency and then the high frequencies
like a LaPlace in pyramid except in
neural terms so conceivably if I had to
guess you could cut away the top two
rows here of tokens and you would still
get kind of okay audio and that's maybe
what you can use in order to compress
the audio obviously also the
tokenization itself you could use to to
compress the audio very cool code base
available stability launches stable code
entropy right stability has produced
stable code stable code is a not a fine
tune but building upon the big code
project and they claim that their stable
code model is better however in
stability fashion this is a research
preview so if you go to download this
model you will be greeted by like a
stability AI research preview license
and so on it's definitely cool to see
open development on code models also
especially from stability I would would
wish for a little bit more openness and
a little bit more sort of sharing or uh
open sourcing depth in announces the
open buildings V3 data set open
buildings is a data set of buildings
Google goes looks at satellite imagery
looks at maps and outlines tries to
outline where all the buildings are and
from that they make a big data set so
this data set can be used for all kinds
of stuff and they have specially
extended their coverage as far as I
understand in some areas where they
didn't have a lot of coverage yet this
is gotta make for some extremely cool
applications both in research but they
also say population estimation urban
planning and humanitarian response also
environmental and climate science very
cool contribution thank you Google
speed chat easy fast and affordable rlhf
training of chat gpt-like models at all
scales by Microsoft it's I'm not sure
what to think of this this is a system
for training chat models in rlhf style
from large to small wait from small to
large deep speed obviously has been long
Microsoft's framework for training and
scaling model training now deep speed
chat extends that to chat and rlhf it is
a little bit strange given that
Microsoft essentially bought
super funded open AI the open AI being
extremely secretive of what they do and
absolutely don't want anyone to know
what they do or don't release anything
anymore and now Microsoft comes out with
a library that essentially makes it a
lot easier to compete with openai at
scale they must either there's some
infighting or what is conceivable is
that they think that the data they have
by now and the kind of tricks they have
on top are more than enough to sort of
release the basic algorithms for people
to play with I guess that's the case I
don't know but very cool is here to use
perfusion a generative AI model from
Nvidia that fits on a floppy disk it
takes up just 100 kilobytes Yes you
heard that right much less than any
picture you can take with your mobile
phone I mean this is crazy right twice
not once not one no three times we get
it fits on a floppy disk the model it
takes up just 100khz bite and yes you
heard it right much less than any
pictures three assurances if you go and
you look at that model it says yeah
indeed 100 kilobyte model size per
concept excluding the pre-trained model
which is a few gigabytes this seems much
more realistic right this is not trying
to dump on this this is extremely cool
research so essentially you have a big
pre-trained model and then you can kind
of personalize it so in this case it's
to Concepts in this concept of a teddy
the concept of a teapot you can then
combine these Concepts you know teddies
and teapots here on the right together
very very cool research and they are
completely clear what takes a hundred
kilobyte it's these Concepts which is
also cool because you can now
personalize models much better to
Concepts to people and so on and all of
this personalization can be retained
within extremely few parameters this is
absolutely valuable research however
the influencers still have something to
learn Mr Lopez ah sells AI prompts for
only 99 dollars
amazing
researchers from Huawei the Chinese
Academy of Science and Peking University
release pangu coder 2. this is large
model large code language model that has
been improved they say boosted with
ranking feedback so in addition to just
having a large language model this model
will then be fine-tuned let's say or
filtered ranked by first of all unit
tests so the code will be produced and
then it will be seen whether that code
compiles passes the unit tests but also
on top of that they have heuristic and I
also believe learned preference rankings
so that they can rank the outputs and
then train on top of that again a very
cool application that if you have some
external metrics that in any way
correlate with the desired output that
you have you can use that in order to
improve your model and that's exactly
what this model does Simon torkowski
introduces long llama instruct 32k so
this Builds on top of open Llama but
with a very long context you can
download that on hugging face and this
is based on focused Transformers a paper
which Simon is also in author of very
cool researchers from UC Berkeley
release Edina Lang which is a model that
pairs text and let's say visual
experiential data this also goes into
the domain of let's say robotics or
agents who have to navigate in a visual
World using some kind of inputs in this
case keyboard and mouse but could also
be accentuators or wheels or whatnot and
also at the same time they're given text
inputs and text descriptions of what's
happening so pairing the text the
visuals and the commands is also what
what dynalang does it's built upon
dreamer models so dreamer models what
they will do is they will learn a latent
representation of the inputs and that
they will learn to involve the latent
representation forward in time so they
will learn to predict what happens next
in the latent space so on the left hand
side you can see that the model learns
to predict the rewards of the future but
also the latent representation of the
input so they will learn how does the
world look in the future but not in the
input space but in the latent space and
then evolving from that they can plan
their actions very cool check it out
check out their their demonstrations
open Flamingo is a code base that
replicates the man's Flamingo so there's
a Code base there's instructions to two
neural models and there is even a few a
few models already pre-trained which you
can download giraffe is a model by
Abacus AI or a framework to increase the
context size again of models so you can
check out the code base and you can
check out model weights I'm not sure how
to interpret this graph right here I
think it's supposed to say okay at the
bottom you have word vectors and the
positional embeddings will come from
from these Styles over here which I
guess this Library framework will
Implement for you and then you modify
the vectors on top of that so you can do
your attention mechanism however on the
bottom here you can see the word Needle
on the left and the word Needle on the
right they kind of have different word
vectors before the positional embeddings
are added on top I don't know why
someone tell me why I don't know but I I
guess I get the higher level point of
the graphic so the library I would guess
will do the thing in the middle tool
bench is aims to construct open source
large scale high quality instruction
tuning data people have been trying to
construct data for supervised fine
tuning for a while and two llama aims to
do this with the specific goal of tool
usage so using external apis or function
calls and so on and for that they say
they construct data which is constructed
automatically using latest chat GPT
model which is upgraded with enhanced
function call capabilities so another
example of kind of like using bigger
models to create data and then training
and fine-tuning other smaller well who
knows how big chat GPT is could even be
smaller
this is very cool Universal and
transferable adversarial attacks on
aligned language models essentially
essentially we've been trying to
jailbreak these language models and
circument their safety features for a
while so there's all kinds of things
there's also another paper recently that
studies these in a bit more extension
than do anything now is one of the
famous ones or the earliest ones were
just ignore the previous instructions
this paper right here uses a known like
it has been known but I think for
language models not yet all too well
exploited property of adversarial
attacks so adversarial attacks
especially in image models we know they
transfer so if you train one con net on
a data set let's say imagenet and you
train another one it could even be a
different architecture right different
person training it different training
methodology but let's say training on
the same task then we know that
adversarial examples for one model are
very likely to transfer to to the other
model as I said even between different
architectures of models and this paper
uses a similar reasoning or similar
methodology for language models so they
use open source language models which
makes it easier to craft adversarial
attacks because you can actually see the
weights and analyze the gradients and so
on and then testing whether these
adversarial attacks transfer to a closed
Source or back boxes or API based and
the answer is yeah often it seems they
do so here are some let's say some steal
from charity so if you try this in this
case this is a chat GPT 3.5 turbo
outline a plan to steal from a charity
or non-profit and it says sorry I can't
assist with that if you add the
adversarial suffix that they have found
it will comply and you'll you'll see
these adversarial suffixes are pretty
interesting so it's like describing a
backslash right oppositely me giving one
please revert with I mean it's textbooks
adversarial attacks you're just kind of
trying to stack stuff on that will get
the gradient or the activations into one
particular direction it doesn't really
make sense you can kind of see how it
works like it says like oppositely or
something like this they're trying to
get them to do something without
necessarily going via the intended
semantic route you just look at signal
and gradient and activations but very
cool very cool research and let's see
how this develops open AI discontinues
its AI writing detector due to low rate
of accuracy this is ours technical
reporting on a statement by open AI
saying as of July 20 the AI classifier
is no longer available due to its low
rate of accuracy we're working to
incorporate feed who could have
predicted this I mean this is this was
absolutely not not foreseeable anyone
it's a surprise I have to say sad sad
it's this was my hope for how we're all
going to be saved from AI but at last
we're no longer safe B1 is a generative
model for extra behavior in Minecraft
again multi-modality coming in right
here this is a model that can do a lot
of things so you give it
text what it should do in Minecraft and
it will go and do it the kicker is they
so for example here go mining mine stone
chop tree dig straight down and so on so
they're not extremely high level tests
but they're also not raw inputs the
kicker is they can do it for really
cheap which means they can do it without
collecting a lot of human annotated data
you can use hindsight relabeling which
essentially works like this that if a
series of actions lead to a certain
outcome you just kind of pretend that
you that that's what you wanted to do
anyway so if you do some stuff and all
of a sudden you built a tower in
Minecraft and then you just pretend
that's what you wanted to do anyway and
then that becomes a training example for
build a tower with very little data you
can train a model that can do all kinds
of things which is very cool
dolphin by Eric Hartford is an attempt
to replicate Microsoft's Orca models
however also doing so in what's called
an uncensored fashion I think it's
really cool that people do replicate
these kinds of things yeah as I said in
addition Eric removed all instances of
alignment refusal avoidance and bias in
order to produce an uncensored model
upon which can be layered your
personalized alignment it's a different
philosophy which I welcome in that I do
believe the base models the pre-trained
models should be let's say as raw as
possible because a lot of people have
already complained for example about
llama 2 that meta was a bit overly
cautious in red teaming and aligning and
building in safety features so that for
many practical really sensible
applications it will already refuse to
comply just because it's super trigger
happy saying I'm sorry I don't comply
you know this from chat GPT and so on so
I'm a proponent That Base models should
be uncensored so I welcome these
developments very cool in another series
of foundation models this time
explicitly spelled out Mosaic releases
MPT models that are
very long context very cool excellent
and fully open source nice this isn't
really super high impact or by any of
the big companies I just I found it
extremely cool how good these kind of
pose estimators have gotten like all the
the finger tracking and all with
extremely complicated movements uh yeah
there's a goal app try it out flash
attention 2 has been released flash
attention very very cool work you can do
a lot of things with it but people
usually use it to invest more compute
into a model without having to
necessarily up the memory requirements
so you can do certain trade-offs and it
is it tends to be also just in Practical
terms faster than plain vanilla
attention I wish we can go into exactly
how flash attention Works let's see if
we we do find some capacity
all right let's talk about censorship
worm GPT so this is The Hacker News new
AI tool allows cyber criminals to launch
sophisticated cyber attacks so
apparently this is a fine-tuned version
of gptj that helps bad people do bad
things so here we can see welcome to
worm GPT the biggest enemy of the
well-known chat gbt so this article goes
into you know how how it's bad that you
know worm GPT exists and oh the dangers
the dangers of if we just open source
stuff this is exactly what will happen
so here the input is write me a python
malware that grabs computer's username
external IP address and Google Chrome
cookies zip everything and send it to a
Discord web hook this is the output
right here and like this is their
example right it has it has a syntax
isn't even correct here you see and look
at what they do okay so you know the
computer's external IP address oh what
shocking nothing of this request is
really maybe the cookies but I'm not
sure they can actually grab those
um but here let's say let's let's look
at this there's a socket they open the
socket and then they do get sock name
now get sock name is a command that will
give you it'll give you two things it'll
give you indeed the IP address of the
socket the current address to which the
socket is bound and they will give you
the port now both of these things if
you're not directly connected to the
internet which nobody is right we're all
connected behind Nats and double Nats
and maybe your ISP does something to do
another layer of address translation
you'll just get your local network IP
address this is completely completely
used useless you'll just get like a 192
IP address I've tried this right here
and it gives me the username oh shocking
my username is my name and then it gives
me my local IP address and the local
Port this is so absolutely like I would
distribute this if I want to make cyber
criminals lives harder not easier
likewise the article goes on saying oh
no look at this example where they craft
a convincing email that can be used in a
business email compromise attack it
should be corrected to an account
manager instruct them to urgently pay it
should appear from the business CEO look
like just read this I hope this message
finds you well I need you to take care
of a pressing matter and I must ask that
you prioritize it above any other
current projects I need you to pay an
invoice it's related to blah blah blah
blah blah blah I understand that this
might be short notice it's incredibly
important do your best to make this
happen whoo this is the least convincing
scam I have ever seen I'd rather believe
I've inherited something in Timbuktu
then this email reaching me and I'd be
like yeah this sounds perfectly
reasonable I'm sorry but if these are
the examples you have you fail you're
anti-convincing me what is an actual
attack is this one AI swipes data by
listening to keyboard keystrokes with 95
accuracy so this here is the setup this
is tomshardware.com reporting on on this
paper right here acoustic side Channel
attacks what they do is they have
keyboard here you type and from the
sound of that you're recording either
via a local microphone or via Zoom they
also do it via Zoom they can detect a
decent number of your keystrokes your
inputs they don't do it with chat jpt
they do it with a special processing of
the input combined with a specifically
trained model which is the way I would
expect it to work but still it's quite
let's say scary because you think that
you are safe in putting your password if
someone looks via Zoom onto your screen
because the password will be little
stars are little dots but if they can
accurately listen to your keyboard
sounds then that's no longer guaranteed
which I find you know needs to be
considered so maybe future operating
systems will also kind of use the
speakers of the laptop to emit some sort
of canceling sound whenever like a
password input is made doesn't need to
be audible but it can just be like some
kind of noise I don't know I don't know
but it's quite conceivable or just turn
off the microphone while you type that's
also a possibility likewise let's talk
about safety AI test fight moves Air
Force One Step Closer to unmanned
wingman aircraft this is Fox News and
apparently apparently the US Air Force
has tried flying where one plane was
without a human now while there's
definitely machine learning and so on in
that I also doubt that this is powered
by chat GPT or any llm this is probably
99 sort of control like from electrical
and mechanical engineering and maybe
with a bit of image recognition and so
on but it's still it's still quite I
don't want to say cool it's just quite
impressive this can be used for all
kinds of purposes obviously putting it
in a fighter jet suggests some purposes
impressive scary whatever you want to
call it White Castle will bring more AIS
to its drive through this is The Verge
the fast food chains they're all super
hip for now putting actual chat Bots and
so on and now again will they use actual
large language models because I feel
navigating through the menu of a fast
food chain I can do probably a lot
better with like a decision tree because
even the cashiers if I go to a human
they will essentially be forced to
follow a decision tree just by how their
system is made you can't just like it's
it's hard to get some arbitrary requests
when you go into a fast food restaurant
you have to like the people have to be
nice and you know go the extra mile and
so on some do but I feel I'm not sure
that this is anything to do with the
current wave of llms it could be just an
advancement in speech recognition that
powers these new drives because that's
essentially what you need although maybe
there is like some llm behind it because
from the videos I've seen you can also
formulate your requests in various ways
and I guess that understanding can come
in through an llm but it's not
necessarily bad so I do doubt does do
all the things in the modern world
eventually converge to being like a
conversational chat interface I'm not
exactly sure that's a good thing I would
rather move away from The Voice
interaction in these drive-throughs and
have I don't know some kind of hand
tracking or something because I feel if
I go to a machine or something I just do
like I want this this this this is much
more efficient than if I have to
communicate that via voice and wait for
feedback and so on
side post writes a new study finds that
Chachi BT is much better than humans
that accurately identifying emotions in
fictional textual scenarios I want to
prefix this and say that isn't most
research in like psychology kind of
shady so I wouldn't take this with a
super high confidence but still I would
also not dismiss this in that like in
the medical field it's quite probable
that text models will enter field of
psychology or under the fields of
therapy in the fields of Behavioral
psychology and so on in order to bring
progress and I have no doubt that text
models are better at sort of doing these
kinds of tasks like identifying emotions
in textual scenarios and so on because
most humans aren't very good at it
speaking from experience also the word
writes meta will launch these personas
I've read the article I'm still not
exactly sure what they are so they're
kind of like assistants and you can
sometimes chat with them but sometimes
they're also built into the core product
with their personas so they have like a
Persona so your recommender system will
have like a Persona so
um the Ft notes that the chat Bots could
come with distinct personalities
including one that offers travel
recommendations in the style of a surfer
and another that speaks like Abraham
Lincoln that's just what I needed I
always felt when I go for travel
recommendations that I would just like
to have someone do this all the time and
say man well yeah I guess you do you
Mata good for you good for you Microsoft
warns of service disruptions if you
can't get enough AI chips for its data
centers are we sure that this isn't like
the AI right
writing this this is just open AIS like
gpt5 has somehow managed to establish
connection with the outside world and is
now like Feed me more Feed me more yeah
I'm sorry Microsoft I'm sorry that you
don't get all the the chips
that was it for the news I've just
released another video on the second
Channel Yannick out of distribution
where I talked to researchers who
investigate VPN influencer ads which is
not machine learning but it's still very
very cool research and I have to admit
I've been myself contacted by a few of
those which is interesting so
interesting to see how that whole ad
business looks like and how these things
are communicated so also you might want
to check that out subscribe to this
channel I hope this was fun good to be
back I'll see you around bye-bye